[Aplausos]
de onde vem os alimentos
acredito que todos aqui pelo menos uma
vez hoje duas vezes já se alimentaram né
a gente se pergunta de onde que vem
aquilo que estava dentro do prato e
sempre causa uma certa dúvida a gente
olha para aquilo e eu pergunto pra vocês
quem aqui não sabe de fato de onde veio
tudo que estava dentro do prato que a
gente como eu levantei a mão
bom eu mesmo também levanta a mão
a gente não sabe de fato a gente não
consegue a fundo e descobrir tudo o que
tem ali como é criado de onde é
produzido
mas de fato aquilo tudo sai da ujs das
mãos ao meu ver dos produtores rurais
dos dois criadores pra gente conversar
sobre isso eu vou ter uma breve conversa
porque é um assunto muito longo e eu
trago de começa aqui dois paradigmas que
a gente tem a gente ouve que nos causam
às vezes uma segurança ou às vezes um
certo medo na gente transgênicos
transgênicos aquele te dentro de um
triângulo nas embalagens né pra nós pode
causar medo mundo hoje morrem cerca de
100 mil crianças por falta de vitamina a
ao mesmo tempo 500 mil crianças no mundo
perdem a visão por ano também por falta
de vitamina existe um arroz desenvolvido
por transgenia chamado golden raiva ou
dourado que ele possui uma quantidade de
no mínimo três vezes mais vitamina á
dentro do grão de arroz
já ele nascido no campo por si só esse
alimento substituído no prato dessas
pessoas
ele já solucionaria esse problema com as
crianças é um alimento transgênico
por outro lado a insulina de que muitas
pessoas precisam e têm problemas
ela foi originado através da transgenia
de uma bactéria né que proporcionou a
produção de insulina é uma bactéria
transgênica
mas claro que ao mesmo tempo muitos
alimentos hoje chegam à nossa mesa
contaminados por conta de que a
transgenia faz com que as plantas
recebam produtos químicos cada vez
maiores quantidades e não morro
então também ele pode causar problema
certo outro paradigma são os produtos
orgânicos
esses nos causam insegurança de imediato
quando a gente toca nesse assunto né
produtos orgânicos né
existe um caso no mundo muito muito
interessante o urt orgânico produzido na
europa onde uma grande empresa destinou
uma região na europa para a produção
desse produto
ela pegou uma região onde os produtores
lá produziam de tudo garantiu um
diversos alimentos que davam segurança
alimentar e destinou toda aquela área
para a produção de leite né e ali então
as pessoas ficarão vulneráveis
somente a produção de leite por conta
que essa indústria que produzir somente
e iogurte orgânico então por mais que
tem um nome lá orgânico à tarde um
produto comum no nosso dia a dia
há toda uma região por trás perdeu a
segurança alimentar por não ter produção
de outros alimentos né
por outro lado regiões do mundo onde não
se conseguia mais produzir alimento por
altíssima as cargas de produtos químicos
hoje consegue produzir alimentos
novamente por ter implantado o sistema
orgânico a gente entender um pouco de
uma forma muito rápida que é um assunto
bem grande
eu divido agricultura em duas grandes
formas de produção produção convencional
de alimentos ea produção orgânica de
alimentos certos produção convencional
de alimentos é aquela produção onde o
agricultor onde aquela forma de produção
ocupa de toda a tecnologia presente para
produzir ou seja ela vai ocupar de
produtos químicos ela vai ocupar de
transgenia ela vai ocupar de
fertilizantes
tudo o que tem possível também ela vai
ocupar de produtos naturais para
produzir alimentos
certo é esse tipo de agricultura que ele
é responsável que se produza
a quantidade necessária porque se
alimente grande grande quantidade de
pessoas que se alimente a população
mundial
ela que produz grande quantidade de
alimentos né
é a forma da agricultura onde os
alimentos são mais predispostas a
estarem contaminados
onde a gente pode ter o contato com
alimento e se contaminar por que por que
usam produtos químicos e às vezes por
dia as orientação o produtor acaba
usando demasiadamente de forma errônea e
tendo contaminação da julho então na
agricultura convencional todo alimento
vai ser contaminado porque o agrotóxico
não não é isso que acontece
o agrotóxico o produto químico usado ele
é pesquisado feito de uma forma que ele
é fornecido de uma forma concentrado
para que se use mais que a aplicação
dele durante o ciclo se degrade não seja
possível no sigo desculpa nossa
alimentação e também não causa efeitos
colaterais nem acumulativos no nosso
corpo de outro lado a gente tem a
produção orgânica de alimentos à
produção orgânica é essa sim de uma
forma geral a gente pode ser que ela
mais segura segura porque ela se ocupa
de insumos da própria natureza né ela
vai procurar até pela observação da
natureza ferramentas insumos
o próprio dunga os próprios defensivos
pra que ela combata o ataque de pragas e
consiga produzir alimentos
a gente tem um exemplo um exemplo
prático disso para controlar o inseto na
agricultura orgânica pode usar por
exemplo uma galinha uma régua ou um
extrato de alguma planta já presente
dentro da área colocado na área de
produção para que esse inseto não cause
dano
lá na convencional usariam um agrotóxico
e aqui usaria essa outra forma
o agricultor orgânico então ela tem
maiores chances de ter um alimento mais
saudável
só que ela não consegue ainda produzir
grandes quantidades quantidade de
alimento
então ela não tem toda essa facilidade
de alimentar essa demanda grande que a
gente acaba colocando os produtores mas
orgânica também pode nos colocar alguns
mas como eu já falei antes daquela
produção de iogurte orgânico e também o
uso desses insumos orgânicos né seja um
pó de rocha um extrato presente na
natureza né sulfato de cobre por exemplo
que já tá ali naturalmente ele pode
contaminar o alimento orgânico e assim
contaminar a gente acumulando metal
pesado no nosso corpo então o que a
gente pode tentar tirar de prática de
sala dessa comparação tanto um quanto o
outro pode oferecer alimento seguro como
oferecer um alimento perigoso
o que a gente pode fazer esse é um
talvez seja uma centelha que eu deixo
vocês que quando a gente se deparar com
alimentos no supermercado quando a gente
fosse alimentar de qualquer forma que se
oferecer um alimento que a gente olha se
questione não só compre não só receba
tente entender de onde vem
e quando a gente vai entender de onde
vem a gente vai descobrir uma coisa
alimento vende agricultor agricultor
criador é o responsável pela agricultura
não existe outra forma a gente tem
alimento de qualidade se o agricultor
não tiver uma condição de qualidade para
produzir essa que é a minha visão sobre
cultura não se tem alimento de qualidade
sem ter um agricultor produzindo com
qualidade aonde que vem o julho
eu não ser uma cidade aqui próximo né
desde pequeno nasce na área rural e teve
contato direto com a agricultura
meu pai produtor rural minha família lá
bem pequenininho cuidava da porta de
casa quando muitos de vocês acham que
também fez mas eu cuidar daquilo com
muita força
eu era o responsável por aquela ordem eu
defendi a ela com todo com toda a força
e ela vai produzir todo o alimento que
minha mãe precisava pra colocar na nossa
mesa
com o passar do tempo comecei a entrar
na atividade do meu pai na produção de
arroz
aos 10 anos de idade pilotava acolhedora
sozinho
eu me sentia lá controlando toda a
produção de arroz na propriedade
com o passar do tempo eu fui para a
universidade lá eu tive uma grande
oportunidade
onde eu consegui abri minha visão
entender como agricultura
ela se mantenha onde o trabalho técnico
dos agrónomos influencia para que a
agricultura três a que tive contato em
contato com a produção orgânica de arroz
lá o implantei a produção orgânica de
rosendo a propriedade em pequena escala
né
o zee uma regra de pequim para ajudar na
produção de arroz teve sucesso com
produtividade de arroz orgânico e
atualmente presta serviço por uma grande
corporação química uma multinacional e
também faz consultoria por alguns
produtores de arroz
mantém essa produção de arroz na
propriedade
eu tenho a produção em pequena escala
tem um arroz diferenciado de italiano e
consigo produzir com uma venda direta
pra restaurantes que usam esse tipo de
arroz e vendo essa peça desse contato
tanto lá como internacional ainda
produzindo arroz dentro da minha
propriedade
eu volto a frisar essa importância que a
gente tem com os agricultores tanto ou
mantendo minha produção vem do meu pai
lá produzindo um dando assistência
técnica e também convivendo um pouco a
realidade da multinacional
tanto eu como a grande empresa hoje o
grande olho nosso em cima do produtor
para que ele se mantenha no campo que
produza com força com qualidade
se ele não se mantê la a nossa empresa
não se mantém
eu como profissional não me mantenho e
vocês não vão comer a gente não vai
comer se mal a gente vai correr mal é
disso que a gente precisa mais que isso
então mantenha essa centena vocês vamos
procurar ter mais atenção quando a gente
olha o alimento buscar saber de onde vem
a gente busca e compartilha com idéias
né e provocações entre outros
a minha é de que vocês valorizem os
agricultores para que tenham a
agricultura
de valor um alimento com qualidade
nada de mim seria sem a origem que eu
tenho da minha família do meu pai eu
tive o conhecimento e hoje sou
apaixonado por cultura por isso né
e pretendo manter a vida inteira não só
como como agrônomo
mas se um produtor fornecendo alimento
para todos e de qualidade
agradeço a todos obrigado
[Aplausos]